معنا من رام الله سري عرابي اهلا وسهلا بك
سيد عرابي اي تداعيات فلسطينيه لما جرى
بعد هذا
الاغتيال يعني اولا فيما يتعلق بالشيخ
صالح العروره لا شك ان عمليه الاغتيال هذه
هي عمليه اغتيال مؤلمه وموجعه للفلسطينيين
عموما للكوادر وقيادات وعناصر حركه حماس
لكن هذه العمليه كانت متوقعه في الحقيقه
يعني بمعنى ان التحريض على الشيخ صالح
العروره هو تحريض قديم منذ فتره طويله لا
سما وان الاحتلال كان يحمل الشيخ صالح
العروره المسؤوليه عن العديد من اعمال
المقاومه في ساحه الضفه الغربيه وذلك قبل
عمليه س7 اكتوبر والحرب العدوانيه على
قطاع غزه بعد هذه الحرب العدوانيه على
قطاع غزه اعلن الاحتلال الاسرائيلي نيته
اغتيال قيادات حركه حماس التي تعيش خارج
الارض المحتله واضح ان بنيامين نتنياهو
كان يبحث عن صوره انتصار بالدرجه الاولى
ومن ثم ارسل الطائره المسيره الى بيروت
يبدو انه راى ان عمليه الاغتيال هناك سوف
تكون اسهل من اي مكان اخر ومن ثم مره اخرى
هو يريد ان يسوق نفسه يريد ان يظهر نفسه
انه قادر على الفعل وفي الوقت نفسه يريد
ان يؤكد على الهيمنه الاسرائيليه في هذه
المنطقه وان اسرائيل لا يغل يدها اي شيء
ومن ثم هو انتهك السياده اللبنانيه في
الحقيقه هذه ليست فقط رساله لحزب الله او
محاوله جس نبض للنظر ماذا يمكن ان يفعل
حزب الله بتنفيذ عمليه اختيال من هذا
النوع في قلب المساحه الامنيه لحزب الله
في قلب لبنان في قلب الضاحيه اي الجنوبيه
اي لكن ايضا هذا انتهاك الحقيقه في
السياده اللبنانيه يعني هذه ضربه موجهه
لكل لبنان وليست فقط ضربه موجهه لحركه
حماس على وجه التحديد وعلى وجه الخصوص ومن
الواضح تماما ايضا ان بنيامين نتنياهو
يسعى لخلط الاوراق في هذه الحرب العدوانيه
على قطاع غزه بتنفيذ عمليه الاغتيال هذه
في الساحه اللبنانيه ربما يسعى ايضا من
خلال تنفيذ عمليه الاغتيال هذه الى
استبقاء الحمايه الامريكيه والدعم
الامريكي والنفوذ الامريكي والتغطيه
الامريكيه خشيه من ردود افعال من حزب الله
انا لا اعتقد ان عمليه الاغتيال هذه من
شانها ربما ان تصرف الانظار عن الحرب
العدوانيه الجاريه في قطاع غزه بالعكس هذه
عمليه الاغتيال جاءت في سياق هذه الحرب
العدوانيه على قطاع غزه في حين ان بنيامين
نتنياهو اراد ان يسجل صوره انتصار ولكنه
في الحقيقه من جهه اخرى اكد على وحده
الشعب الفلسطيني وعلى وحده المعركه اغتال
اي رئيس وزعيم وا اقليم الضفه الغربيه
ونائب رئيس حركه حماس في ساحه موجوده خارج
الارض المحتله وبالتالي بنيمين ياه بصوره
او باخرى جمع الفلسطينيين في هذه الصوره
جمع ساحه الضفا الغربيه الى ساحه غزه الى
الساحه خارج الارض المحتله التداعيات
بطبيعه الحال الى حد كبير هي منوطه
بالاحتمالات احتمالات رد حزب الله ماذا
يمكن ان يرد حزب الله ماذا يمكن ان يفعل
حزب الله هل سوف تتسع وتيره هذه المعركه
هل ثمت حسابات اخرى من شانها ربما ان تحول
دون اتساع وتيره المعركه او وتيره تدخل
حزب الله في هذه المواجهه الاسناديه الى
جانب المقاومه داخل قطاع غزه انا اعتقد ان
الاحتمالات مفتوحه وهذه العمليه لا شك
انها عادت بخلط الاوراق من جديد لكنها مره
اخرى هي جزء من الحرب العدوانيه على
الفلسطينيين في كل مكان توحد الفلسطينيين
من جديد في في هذه المعركه العدوانيه التي
يشنها الاحتلال الاسرائيلي نعم اشرت الى
صوره الانتصار هذا التعبير الذي يتردد
باستمرار في الاوساط الاسرائيليه والذين
يبحثون عنه في غزه لكنهم لم يظفروا به هل
تعتقد بانهم سعوا الى ان ان يعوضوا عنه في
في بيروت في الضاحيه
الجنوبيه يعني هو اولا الحقيقه سياسه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في تنفيذ عمليات خارج
الارض المحتله ليست جديده وتحديدا فيما
يتعلق بحركه حماس ليست هذه عمليه الاغتيال
الاولى التي تستهدف كوادر او قيادات من
حركه حماس خارج الارض المحتله الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي اغتال عز الدين الشيخ خليل في
دمشق عام 2004 فادي البطش في ماليزيا
محمود المبحوح في دبي حاول اغتيال خالد
مشعل في عمان الاردن عام 1997 هي بالتاكيد
جزء من من سياسه اسرائيليه تنم من جهه ما
من جهه تاسيسيه اصليه على طبيعه الصراع
وعلى طبيعه المواجهه والمعركه ما بين حركه
حماس وما بين الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لكن في
سياق هذه المعركه على وجه التحديد في سياق
هذه الحرب العدوانيه على الفلسطينيين في
قطاع غزه وازاء التعثر الاسرائيلي في
مواجهه المقاومه داخل قطاع غزه وعجز
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي عن تحقيق ان انجازات
واضحه او انتصارات واضحه سواء الاهداف
الكليه الكبرى التي رفعها للقضاء على حركه
حماس في قطاع غزه او استعاده الاسرى
الاسرائيليين داخل قطاع غزه بالقوى
العسكريه او فرض الهزيمه او فرض التنازل
او فرض الاستسلام على حركه حماس داخل قطاع
غزه او اغتيال يحيى السنوار او اغتيال
محمد الضيف الى اخره اذاء مثل هذا الفشل
بالتاكيد سوف يسع الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
للبحث عن اهداف قد تكون اسهل بحسب طبيعه
الساحه ليس مستغربا يعني لا احد في
الحقيقه يشك الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قادر على
ارسال طائره مسيره واغتيال قيادات
فلسطينيه او لبنانيه او اغتيال قيادات
مقاومه من اي اتجاه كان في الساحه
اللبنانيه بالتاكيد هو يبحث عن صوره
انتصار نتنياهو يسعى لتعزيز
موقع الا سيد سري عرابي اسمح لي نتنياهو
كان يقال عنه بانه لا
يمانع في ان يحرق البلد كله جراء ان يستمر
هو في منصبه ولكن الكل كان يتحدث عن غزه
تحديدا الان هو يوسع نطاق المواجهه هل
تعتقد بانه لا يمانع ايضا حتى في اتساع
رقعه الحرب او حتى في حرب اقليميه نظير ان
يستمر مره اخرى في
الحكم يعني هناك بالتاكيد هناك اكثر من
اعتبار لسياسات بنيامين نتنياهو في هذه
المعركه بالتاكيد بنيامين نتنياهو يعني
ينظر لليوم التالي ينظر للاسبوع التالي
ينظر ماذا يمكن ان يجري له في نهايه هذه
المعركه معروف تماما موقف المجتمع
الاسرائيلي ومعروف تماما حاله الخلخله
التي يعانيها بنيمين نتنياهو على مستوى
مكانته السياسيه في الوسط السياسي
الاسرائيلي في الكيان الاسرائيلي عموما
وكذلك حتى حلفاء بنيمين نتنياهو في اليمين
الذ الذين يعني مثلوا له غطاء طوال
المرحله الماضيه وبالتاكيد يعني ليس ليس
الفلسطينيون يعني الذين يقولون ان بنيامين
تنياه يدير هذه الحرب بطريقه شخصيه ولاهث
ضيقه للغايه يعني حتى شركاء بنيامين
نتنياهو في مجلس الحرب المعارضه
الاسرائيليه العديد من الاصوات السياسيه
الاصوات الاستراتيجيه قيادات اسرائيليه
سابقه قيادات اعلاميه وصحفيه ناقده
لسياسات بنيامين نتنياهو تتحدث عن ذلك
وبالتالي بالتاكيد من ضمن اهداف بنيامين
نتنياهو من خلط الاوراق اهداف شخصيه
لبنيامين نتنياهو على وجه التحديد وعلى
وجه الخصوص لكن بالتاكيد بنيامين نتنياهو
لا يستطيع ان يقود الكيان الاسرائيلي في
قضايا امنيه وعسكريه واستراتيجيه معقده
وخطيره للغايه يعني بمفرده لا شك ان ربما
كان هناك نوع من التوافق بين يمين بين
بنيامين نتنياهو وجنرالات الجيش والمؤسسه
الامنيه الاسرائيليه لان الجميع معني
بالخروج بصوره انتصار من هذه المعركه وليس
فقط بنيامين نتنياهو ايضا من الممكن ان
نقول ربما يسعى بنيامين نتنياهو لجر
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لكي تدخل
معركه بالنيابه عن اسرائيل اظن ان اسرائيل
غير قادره على ان تدخل معركه على جبهتين
يعني جبهه قطاع غزه وجبهه لبنان ولذلك
ربما قرات اسرائيل يعني مؤشرات ما من
انسحاب حامله الطائرات الامريكيه من
المنطقه وارادت استدعاء الولايات المتحده
من جديد للنيا لحمايه اسرائيل بالحد
الادنى وربما القيام بالنيابه عن اسرائيل
في تصفيه حسابات اسرائيل مع القوى
الاقليميه المعاديه لاسرائيل الموجوده في
المنطقه نعم اشرت قبل قليل
الى صالح عر عاروري باعتباره
ايه مسؤول ملف الضفه الغربيه غزه هو من من
الضفه الغربيه مسؤول الضفه الغربيه عفوا
في في القياده العسكريه هل تعتقد بان
اغتيال احد ابناء الضفه الغربيه قد يساهم
في
مزيد اذكاء ما يجري الان في الضفه باختصار
لو
سمحت بالتاكيد سيكون هناك حاله تفاعل
كبيره على المستوى الجماهيري وعلى المستوى
الشعبي وعلى المستوى العاطفي والمعنوي
والنفسي للجماهير داخل الضفه الغربيه انا
اعتقد ان الشيخ صالح العاروري يعني يحظى
بمكان خاصه ما بين الفلسطينيين داخل الضفه
الغربيه طبعا من نافله القول ان الضفه
الغربيه ايضا تعيش حاله من تصعيد المقاومه
قبل احداث 27 اكتوبر وما تزال حتى هذه
اللحظه واليوم ارتقى العديد من الشهداء في
ساحه الضفه الغربيه فهذه الممارسه
الاسرائيليه في الحقيقه من شانها ان تذكي
هذه الروح الثوريه للفلسطينيين داخل ساحه
الضفه الغربيه